benjamin castaldi est ce qui vous est
déjà arrivé un truc de ouf oui une fois
dans la rue j'ai croisé quelqu'un et il
me regarde et fais toi
franchement tu es nul mais il a continué
et il a rajouté et en plus je tends non
oui un vrai quoi que cinq ans c'est la
vie des autres et non c'était
honnêtement je regrette
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque du cycle est vous n'êtes pas
d'ailleurs rien fait à six si j'étais
moi j'adore ça t'arrive et qu'une fausse
[Rires]
bien que vous avez vous avez quelque
chose ou pas oui n ya pas très longtemps
weight à la gare montparnasse
tranquillement au relais h en train
d'acheter des magazines des livres etc
et un article qui met sauté dessus mais
je m'attendais pas du tout j'étais
pencher sur les magazines et il m'a dit
ah ça tombe bien vous soyez là vous
alors je vous aime bien mais arrêtez
travail ex est donc deux coups sûrs que
c'est vrai et même et après j'ai dit que
j'étais un peu sur qu'est-ce que ça
parce que j'ai peur que ça déteigne non
il est parti mais vous voulez pas dix a
déjà des parts à mai mais enfin ni
bonjour ni la première partie tout de
suite cette bonne gilles verdez il est
souvent vers la gare ça c'est du jeune
garde bonjour l'autocritique tout le
monde tourne et lusophones très bon tout
ça si excusez moi aujourd'hui lever le
pied sur le style son luxe secondes et
bien oui alors oui et donc moi une fois
je m'étais loupé un écheveau vous savez
il ya deux ans en fait non vous paierez
deschamps s'est fait prélever chapeau
pourquoi enlever le chapeau oui bien sur
wii et que ça coûte cette histoire ça
coûte ça dépend du nombre de cheveux qui
a mètres mais ça coûte en réalité voici
un peu partout c'est comme vous mais
tout ça
[Applaudissements]
non je veux sont implantées en fosse où
l'implantation combiné plus faim devant
les plus l'épée derrière wayne la
plantation ça change bosson de
l'implantation du rsa vrai boulot c'est
l'artisanat mais est donc enfin bref
voilà donc sa carrière entre 6000 et 10
mille douce ménage une reine des cheveux
ça dépend vous ça coûterait rien
pratiquement karité capillaire est ce
que tu veux ajouter là ça fait trop de
poids la linguère d'un goût plus la
gaffe tagab
merci à la veille alors vous allez voir
le surnom que vous ont trouvé les
bodin's d'ailleurs à l'instant oui alors
ah bah je crois que vous vouliez plus
alors que je m'étais fait opérer les
cheveux déjà vu ce qu'on appelle un
deuxième jeu parce qu'il avait si on a
la technique ou qui gonfle terriblement
sa soirée ça j'avais remarqué oui c'est
ça elle s'avoue jamais c'était très
gonflé j'avais de l'eau sous la police a
triomphé et j'avais été un peu blafard
sud et quelqu'un m'a appelé jean luc
dans la rue pour cgt jean luc lemoine
c'est catastrophique sur ip ou pas vous
riez aussi à ces bruits et soutien et
sortez pas c'est qu'il faut qu'ils
restent là qu'ils vivent avec sa honte
[Rires]
non mais c'est me laisser son rival qui
a bon truc
allez-y vous citoyen trouver un bon truc
puisque l'essai je ne peux pas passer
une bonne soirée sans certes et un bon
vieux cocktail groseille pamplemousse et
bananes dans mon lunch préféré c'est
quoi c'est quoi hoyos et agathe qui fait
du buzz et de ses affaires balawi avait
dit qu'il n'a il m'a dit ça se voit
c'est écrit marc pas du tout j'ai pas
dit ça c'est du conditions là alors oui
alors oui et donc çà et là
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît les deux
et là je crois ce regard une fille qui
est totalement à mon goût voilà c'est à
dire bien propre sur elle
je m'approche d'elle tranquillement mais
c'est leur fille totalement vos goûts ce
quelqu'un qui est propre
oui au moins c'est la première de nadal
et sa belle-mère vertus père d aimer les
jambes les personnes propre au cra et j
aime gagner les prochains mois vous avez
cassé avec kddi mais si les moustaches
jamais compenser elle sortait vraiment
il dira qu'il ya des gens qu'il ya des
gens qui m'ont dit jean michel nous a
manqué dix minutes non c'est le neveu du
temps de 2 h 2 o 1
le pote de produits là qu'est la
jeunesse à laquelle l'âge de 9 ans neveu
il comprend pas encore le feu et dans le
bar je filme reconnaît donc les chances
de regard je m'approche doucement mais
sûrement et là elle me dit c'est
incroyable comme vous êtes plus gros en
vrai nom ça m'a tuer quoi mais a ouai
ouai lorsque généralement été dégonflé
alors non moi je veux dire votre
histoire était pourrie mais sur twitter
une personne vous a clashé y regarder ni
alors vous allez voir cette folle
polémique
et bien dites donc on lui parle comme un
voeu et certains l'adorent il faut
vraiment être très con pour aimer ce
connard de fils de ce nord
ces mesures est en régression et maxime
et barak s'est pas démontée a répondu je
peux ou liées à la répartie de ouf le
gage peux te dire ayila ces primo ce cas
là c'est pas mal l'inventeur
quand on parle comme un boeuf c'est que
l'on sait a minima conjuguée à ben c'est
pas mal
bages et marie font comme je peux ballet
fin oui l appui de l'yonne et après
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à laisser
passer il avoue tu étais ce message
ah ouais ouais non ce n'est peut-être
pas tout allait bien avant tout cas ce
qui est une très belle réponse
alors c'était il ya environ trois
semaines sur la ligne 3 du métro à havre
caumartin
il ya un jeune qui vient vers moi pour
faire une photo ouais donc il me dit on
peut faire une photo je dis bien sûr il
arrive bien vous savez jean michel ces
gens je ne trouve pas très bon je vous
trouve moyen je vous aime moins que
d'habitude
donc tu as beau essayer gars qui
regardent l'émission et hindi mais vous
êtes quand même moins cons que
jean-michel jeu girardon tcc comme tu es
dans le slalom la lame avoir vu mme g
pas contre jerry pays qu'ils ont le
label on va pas d'en bas noirs on suit
alors isabelle ou bon bah moi ça va être
très rapide installée parce que vous
savez vous savez que je savais pas que
j'étais vieille avant d'intégrer cette
émission le trouvant dans la rue est un
mec qui m'a bornes et qui me dit avec
moi je te kiffe j'te kiffe j'te kiffe de
ouf parce que moi j'ai toujours adoré
les vieilles et laura sabatier et il
ajouté cela dit j'espère que l'intérieur
aussi propre que tu le dis si la partie
c'est bien c'est bien c'est mathieu
mathieu relever le niveau
bon je ne suis je peux parce que moi les
gens m'adorent plutôt globalement connu
une croissance
[Applaudissements]
alors non pas dans le métro mais dans un
restaurant quick est venu voir qu'il est
fan de vous et qui arrivait et je sais
pas été très premier degré et il m'a dit
lâche le lâche le arrête de mère d'anna
tu leur as jamais il est pas pour toi et
si vous mettez ensemble plus jamais je
regarderai l'émission web est ce qui m'a
dit alors ah et où la suite mais alors
excuses michael bay l'expert en chute
le vrai débat c'est ce qu'ils vont en
avoir rien à secouer votre caddie the
banker on est tous mes espoirs
bon c'est sûr qu'il est très délicat car
l'udc
agathe agathe elia jaua tangage je passe
la parole à leurs agathe vous devez le
tenter à la ccva zenten pas beaucoup
d'être drôle non
agathe pas de son tour jean luc nom me
vois ce qui est particulier c'est
comment je marche dans la rue je pense
que c'est pareil pour tout le monde
souvent les gens vous interpelle mai
mais un peu sournoise mans il ose pas
trop d'autres et donc tu marches puis
tenterons quelqu'un accès
et puis ils savent pas trop quitté en
fait c'est 8 je le retourne pas hanouna
retourne pas et jean michel mr fais pas
ci fais pas ta star dont je me retourne
effet sarah s'appelle bien de faire sa
[ __ ] g hanouna situe dans ces cas là bas
je dis bah oui oui je suis jean michel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cina
alors quel est le sens d'une journée
géniale héniart elle est superbe et
kelly maintenant alors ça y est elle
folle 1 celle-ci allez vas-y alors jeté
à la garde savigny-sur-orge c'est albert
days est ce que l'on attend on fait
comme si c'était en 1963 maintenant ça
voulait dire qualité là bas j'ai habité
là bas en finale comme ville tendance au
foehn
merci président le même lycée avec
j'aimerais vraiment y va à 50 ans
d'écart et au lycée et au lycée alors je
veux bien qu'on me dit que j'ai une
grosse tête personne ne dit rien le
lycée elle est passée devant moi ça
compte bah oui au nord
merci merci alors oui et donc du coup au
loin je vois un garçon plutôt pas mal
même très beau donc ça tombe bien c'est
mon chemin
ouais donc je passe devant lui et je me
dis bah peut-être qu'il va me regarder
ou peut-être qu'il va me parler ou
quelque chose comme ça et là donc j'y
arrive en face de lui il me dit wesh
luan à aller
[Applaudissements]
alors l'école à l'âge de mais jamais
rien arrivé at abordant le goujat qui
était pas les chéris